hey youtubers it's Charlie so this week
on arrow the pretty much hit the
fan all the characters are starting to
connect the dots about the different
plot threads and how everything is
connected because everything really is
connected and I think we got a major
teaser for something that's gonna happen
in season 3 if you're finding me for the
first time I do arrow videos every week
along with q and A's and I've been doing
bonus videos just to count down to the
finale
just because arrow has been so awesome
this year so be sure to subscribe to get
everything and leave me suggestions for
what you think those other bonus video
should be about so let's just dig right
in and get started with top 5 moments
careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
the episode yet but here we go number 5
the new arrow cave it may or may not be
a teaser for them getting a new arrow
cave in season 3 I wouldn't be surprised
but Oliver's other base of operations
basically has everything but the gear
and because Felicity and Diggle didn't
know about it it means that Slade and
Isabel don't know about it remember how
I keep saying that team arrow has been
growing this season when you look at
shots like this where the whole team is
hunched over Roy it makes the current
arrow cave look claustrophobic it's
almost like there's barely room to do
salmon ladders as an answer to that the
backup arrow cave or the new arrow cave
looks like there's just wide-open space
it looks much more like Christian Bale's
Dark Knight Batcave
plenty more space for Felicity's gear
and for Oliver to shoot arrows at tennis
balls so don't be surprised if next year
Oliver moves them into that new space
given the addition of Roy this year
Laurel and maybe even Thea I also think
it'd be an easy way for the show to keep
things fresh in season 3 because we've
been in this arrow cave for almost two
years now number four
Ravager returns the favor I like that
they modeled her costume after the comic
book Ravager instead of just giving her
the hockey mask everyone else is wearing
I always love watching Summer Glau
fights so I'm hoping that Nyssa al Ghul
and Sara take her on in the finale in
case you were wondering this picture of
Nyssa is the first official picture
we've had from the finale so she's
definitely gonna be there from a
character standpoint Isabel's major Ark
is pretty much over she's already
accomplished her goal of taking over
Queen industries you know she's even
taking the club and now she's really
just kind of pouring salt on the moon
and getting revenge on Diggle for
killing her the plus side of that being
that most of her time in the last two
episodes is going to be spent dancing
with swords just sit back and enjoy the
show it totally reminds me of serenity
whenever she was killing the reverse
with those two blades number three
Felicity will be your interrogator can
we please have more Felicity double-take
moments like this in season three I just
love how this fake out moment worked
with the larger brother blood army
storyline even when the hits the
fan she still has time to slip in a few
jokes I also loved the way she used her
skills to get the information out of him
instead of Diggle just beating him to
death it's like that pen is mightier
than the sword scene from Indiana Jones
although in this case you would say the
Felicity is mightier than the fist and I
absolutely cannot wait to see all the
gifs of you know felicity with
Wi-Fi number two Laurel in the arrow
cave this was huge and totally
unexpected I knew she'd be helping them
out but I thought it would be under the
radar until the finale or even season
three but I love that she was actually
his call to action and that they took
that moment to remember Tommy but based
on these new developments I would plan
on Laurel acting as the new Quentin you
know if he were a real member of the
team on the inside she could even end up
running for mayor if they don't do that
Oliver Queen mayor storyline from the
comic books I know everyone keeps asking
me about Laurel becoming the Black
Canary but even you know given
everything that's happened and where
Sara's character is at I still feel like
it's too soon for Laurel to put on black
leather and start going off parkour and
my number one moment
team arrow tries to stop Oliver from
committing suicide the best arrow scenes
are always the team scenes especially
when they get so emotional and Felicity
starts to cry it reminded me a lot of
that scene in episode 13 at the campaign
rally where Felicity got so upset she
thought she might lose Oliver and she
just started weeping all over the place
after all they've been through there is
much of a family as you could possibly
be I think that these were the last you
know emotional reflective scenes like
this we're gonna see until the finale
you know it was like that pause and the
action between Moira's death and the
army being released but now that the
army is out it's essentially just going
to be one long continuous explosion
until the finale
the next episode is even called Streets
of Fire but now it's your turn let me
know what your favorite moment was so
closely with wife I brought of the
Bloods army or even Laurel in the arrow
cave some also here's a couple really
big moments that didn't necessarily make
my top 5 but there
really important to the plot first off
all of our revealing himself to brother
blood he was basically trying to reason
with him blood really is slate spawn I
keep saying that he's gonna get thrown
under the bus before the end I did like
that brother blood actually had a plan
for Starling though it kind of reminded
me of when Merlin talked about his plan
for Starling in season one you know save
it by destroying it it sounded very
familiar then there was the Thea plot
she's going to run into Merlin next week
we even saw him in the teaser it sounds
like she's slowly connecting the dots
between Slade Oliver in the island and
because we saw Merlin in his dark Archer
gear I think that she's definitely going
to learn the truth about everything like
really really soon either way she's down
to two options she's either gonna go
with Merlin or she's gonna join team
arrow in season three if you didn't
catch it
Felicity's call at the end was also
really important that was Cisco Ramon
calling her about the mirakuru cure
because the soldiers are so scattered
over the city the cure is probably going
to have to be aerosolized or you don't
airborne or they're gonna have to use a
bomb whatever it is it's gonna be really
cool my last really big moment was
actually kind of funny and it was Slade
calling brother blood pretending to be
his father I thought it was pretty
hilarious given all the talk you did
about his parents of warriors wake
overall I loved the episode I actually
gave it an a-minus but that's only
because there was absolutely no way they
were gonna top the ending from last
week's episode I also can't say enough
about the character development this
season it's been amazing I'm mostly
talking about Laurel but even the core
team members have changed in really
profound ways and obviously we'll
continue to until the finale
Felicity even really showed a light on
that when she told Oliver you've been
trying really hard this year not to kill
people I also love the way they kind of
tease future moments you know we've in
for shadowing into characters dialogue
the most important I think in this
episode was Isabel rochev calling out to
the island I think that they're gonna go
back to the island in the finale
then there was Felicity geeking out on
Amanda Waller's gear it was totally
adorable but I think that she's gonna
get her hands on some of that for season
3 you know kind of tying in with my idea
that they're gonna get a whole new
upgraded arrow cave so let me know what
your final thoughts are on the episode
but like I said next week is basically
gonna be the mirakuru army just
punishing the city and Oliver finding a
way to deliver the cure be sure to
subscribe to get my video and leave me
suggestions for my next bonus
my Q&A video will post tomorrow on
Thursday just like normal
you can actually click here right now to
get that I'll add the annotation as soon
as I post it and you can click here to
get my breakdown of the Justice League
movie thank you so much for watching
I'll see you guys tomorrow
high fives